it was a sea lizard  six feet long days it took to it out  clean it  i was only 11 years old  it's in the british museum  that one was special  [Music]  i've often heard your reputation  discussed in the geographical society in  london  is there something you wanted sir my  wife  she hasn't been at all well of late she  suffers  from melancholia  i want her to walk the shoreline with  you  learn from you i'm not looking for an  apprentice  i would pay a premium for a private  audience  it's not easy work  i don't like the wood  what is it cheap tourist water  [Applause]  [Music]  beautiful  [Music]  it pleases me you struck up a friendship  together  what is it something nothing  [Music]  i don't want to go back to the life i  had before you what about my life  [Music]  you